Beth Rigby Sky News um mrstama you're
making big promises but you have already
you turned on your 28 billion pound a
year investment into green transition
Your Shadow Chancellor said it shows you
can be trusted with the public finances
but doesn't it also suggest as with
brexit tuition fees nationalizations
you're just like all of those other
politicians who can't be trusted to keep
your promises and on a broader political
question if I may you've chosen to be
here in Scotland today rather than sw1
Boris Johnson's out there could or
couldn't be a vote on him later while in
Scotland it seems that the SMP
Stranglehold is finally over Napoleon
said that generals need to be lucky and
you're clearly a lucky General surely
you can't possibly blow it now thank you
thank you I think for the record that
was two questions but I've been
respected nothing less uh on the 28
billion we are doubling down we're not
backing off and it's really important
that we say this uh for two reasons for
the policy position we've adopted the
first is a matter of trust the very
thing you touch on Beth which is we said
that our fiscal rules were in place
Rachel set them out two years or more
ago inflation now is in a completely
different place to where it was two
years ago because the Tories have made
such a mess and done such damage to the
economy but at the same time as we work
through our plans and set out what we'll
do in years one two three showing just
how serious we are it's clear that we
can ramp up that 28 billion pounds and
what I would say better is this when I
say to
um people in the sector that we will
partner with that we want clean Power by
2030. they don't say you're somehow
backing down or lacking ambition they
say whoa that is a real challenge
centrica say it's doable but we're
really going to have to go for it so
there's nothing here to read into any
sense of lacking ambition or backing
down on the second question
um Beth um look
there's a reason that the tourists and
the s p are imploding and it's their
failure in government for a long time
they've been able to avoid any question
about their record and both of them are
now getting questions about their record
and you only have to look at the record
uh and ask the question and it's the
same question of the Tories or the SMP
which is after however many years in
power for each of them do you feel any
better off now than you did when they
started and the answer that question is
no and because it's no we can see the
impact it's having but what I would say
is this we know that we have to earn
every vote we know that we have to go up
again I've said to my shadow cabinet
we've got to be exceptional as we go
forward from here there is no right to
any vote anywhere in the United Kingdom
whether that's you know elsewhere or
here in Scotland we have to earn every
vote I'm I find some comfort in the fact
that the changes we've made to the labor
party both uk-wide and in Scotland put
us in a position where when people look
away from the tours in SNP and to the
opposition they see a change labor party
with answers to the challenges of the
future and I'll end with this doesn't it
speak volumes that the labor party is
today launching a plan for the next
generation of jobs whilst the tourists
are squabbling back in Westminster the
SMP are preaching about promises that
they have broken thank you very much
Beth we'll go to